well thank you very much it's a great
honor to be with the Crown Prince of
Bahrain he is a friend of mine and the
country is a friend of ours we're always
going to be with them and I know they're
always gonna be with us we have a
tremendous relationship militarily but
we have also a tremendous economic
relationship trade and we're going to be
discussing all of those things we'll
certainly be discussing what took place
over the last two days in Saudi Arabia
and we'll be discussing the Middle East
but our relationship has never been
stronger than it is right now and I
think that is largely based on the
relationship that we have so I look
forward to having a discussion Thank You
mr. president
great pleasure to be here well I would
like to say thank the president for
receiving me and my delegation here
today I'm here to convey the greetings
of His Majesty and the people of Bahrain
to strengthen the relationship which is
based on shared values where they
overlap ideals we primarily as the
president said are going to focus on
discussions related to security
enhancement and trade enhancement we
signed today a agreement to purchase
additional purchase our first Patriot
missile battery systems and it couldn't
have come at a better time
good damning absolutely and we seek to
strengthen America's ability to trade
with the world and we have some concrete
ideas on how we can do that well thank
you very much thank you forward to today
and spending time with you and thank you
all very much I'll be doing a news
conference outside in a little while
just prior to the trip we're going to
New Mexico and two other places
two and a half days and many of you will
be with us and I look forward to that
but in particular I look forward to our
meeting thank you
have you seen evidence well it's looking
that way we'll have some pretty good
we're having some very strong studies
done but it's certainly looking that way
at this moment and we'll let you know as
soon as we find out definitively we'll
let you know but it does look that way
well what more I don't want war with
anybody I'm somebody they would like not
to have war we have the strongest
military in the world we've spent more
than a trillion and a half dollars in
the last short period of time when our
military nobody's even come close we
have the best equipment in the world we
have the best missiles and as you say
you just want the Patriot system there's
nothing even close but no I don't want
war with anybody but we're prepared more
than anybody and two and a half years
ago I will tell you it was not the same
thing and with what we've done we've
totally rebuilt our military in so many
different ways but we've rebuilt it and
there's nobody in has the f-35 we have
the best fighter jets the best rockets
the best missiles the best equipment but
with all of that being said we'd
certainly like to avoid it well we have
a lot of options but I'm not looking at
options right now we want to find
definitively who did this we're dealing
with Saudi Arabian we're dealing with
the crown prince and so many other of
your neighbors and we're all talking
about it together we'll see what happens
well I have no meeting scheduled I know
they want to meet I know they're not
doing well as a country Iran has got a
lot of problems right now that two and a
half years ago and even a little bit
more than that when I came in it's hard
to believe it's almost three years but
two and a half to three years ago they
were causing a lot of trouble and we'll
see what happens but we'll let you know
definitively or there were as you know
there are ways to see definitively where
they came from and we have all of those
ways and that's being checked out right
now
well you know there were always
conditions because the conditions if you
look at it these sanctions are not going
to be taken off so the sanctions that's
a condition so you know that's why the
press reported it the biggest thing you
can talk about are the sanctions and
sanctions are massive there's never been
sanctions put on a country like that and
I think they have a tremendous future
but not the way they're behaving we'll
see what happens in terms of this attack
secretary Pompeo and others will be
going over to Saudi Arabia at some point
to discuss what they feel they're going
to make a statement fairly soon but they
also know something that most people
don't know as to where it came from who
did it and will be able to find that out
figure that out very quickly we pretty
much already know the United States is
more prepared than any country and the
history of in any history if we have to
go that way as to whether or not we go
that way we'll see we're going to find
out definitively who did it we have to
speak to Saudi Arabia they have to have
a lot of they have to have a lot in the
game also and you know they're willing
to do that I think everybody knows
they're willing to do that so we'll be
meeting with Saudi Arabia we'll be
talking to Saudi Arabia we'll be talking
to you a II and many of the neighbors
out there that were very close friends
with we're also talking to Europe a lot
of the countries that we're dealing with
whether it's France Germany etc talking
to a lot of different folks and we're
figuring out what they think but I will
tell you that was a very large attack
and it could be met with an attack many
many times larger very easily by our
country but we're going to find out who
definitively did it first
[Music]
do you think I didn't say that why do
you say that I said that we think we
know who it was but I didn't say anybody
but certainly it would look the most
like it was Iran but I did not say it
the way you said you're going to find
out in great detail in the very near
future we have the exact locations of
just about everything you're going to
find out at the right time but it's too
early to tell you that now well they
haven't risen very much and we have
these strategic oil reserves which are
massive and we can release a little bit
of that and other countries including
Bahrain but other countries can be a
little bit more generous with the oil
and you'd bring it right down so now
that's not a problem it went up $5 and
that that is not a problem and you have
to remember we're now the largest
producer of oil and gas in the world so
a lot of people in the old days and this
happened over the last very short period
of time we're number one in the world by
far by far so I never want to be
benefited that way but the fact is there
are those that say we benefit I don't
view that as a benefit but we are
certainly we take in more money than
anybody else from energy not even close
oh I think I think it is certainly the
responsibility of them to do a big big
deal of the defense certainly I also
think it's the responsibility of the
Saudis to if somebody like us which are
the ones are going to help them they I
know that monetarily will be very much
involved in paying for that this is
something that's much different than
other presidents would mention John but
the fact is that the Saudis are going to
have a lot of involvement in this if we
decide to do something they'll be very
much involved and that includes payment
and they understand that fully but
they're going to be look they're very
upset they're very angry they
know pretty much what we know they know
pretty much where they came from and
we're looking for the final checkpoints
and I think you won't be surprised to
see who did it we'll be discussing it
yeah we'll be discussing well we're
gonna see what I mean it's the elections
on Tuesday so like tomorrow so you have
an election tomorrow so I would think it
would be afterwards okay but we you do
have an election big big election
tomorrow in Israel and that'll be a very
interesting outcome it's gonna be close
gonna be a close election I don't want
to comment on the relationship is very
good but I don't want to comment on I
just don't think it's appropriate for me
to comment probably not I don't think
it's ready I don't think we're ready for
that I would do it sometime at some time
at a later future and depending on what
happens I'm sure he'll love coming to
the United States also but no I don't
think it's ready for that I think we
have a ways to go yet well I have great
relationship with the Auto Workers I got
tremendous numbers of votes from the
Auto Workers
I don't want General Motors to be
building plants outside of this country
as you know they've built many plants in
China and Mexico and I don't like that
at all
my relationship has been very powerful
with the Auto Workers not necessarily
the top person or two but the people
that work doing automobiles nobody has
ever brought more companies into the
United States and I have Japan and
Germany and many countries have been
bringing car companies in and opening
plants and expanding plants and big
things are happening are Ohio including
with Lordstown a very positive things
are happening
we have many plants that are either
being renovated or expanded or built new
right now in the United States many more
than we've had for decades and decades
so nobody's been better to the Auto
Workers than me I'd like to see it work
out but I don't want General Motors
building play
in China and Mexico this was before my
watch and I don't think they'll be doing
that I don't think I had meetings with
Mary Barra the head of GM and I don't
want them leaving our country I don't
want a building in China I don't want to
build them in other countries I don't
want these big massive auto plants built
in other countries and I don't think
they'll be doing that anymore you know
General Motors makes most of its money
in the United States and too bad they
spent billions and billions of dollars
outside of the United States before I
got here one of the things very
important than the u.s. MCA which we
have to have approved for the not only
for the unions for the auto workers but
for the farmers and for the
manufacturers for everybody everybody
wants us MCA it's very important even
more so now than it was two weeks ago
but people really want it I'm sad to see
the strike hopefully it's going to be a
quick one no it's never exhausted fact
the Crown Prince can tell you especially
in your part of the world it's never
exhausted until the final 12 seconds is
that right that is correct you never
know what's gonna happen no it's not
exhausted nothing's exhausted we'll see
what happens I think they would like to
make a deal I know they'd like to make a
deal they'd like to do it but they'd
like to do it on certain terms and
conditions that we won't do that but at
some point it will work out in my
opinion the the problem was the deal
that was signed by the previous
administration was a disaster which by
the way would be expiring in a very
short period of time also so you really
don't have a deal you know that deal was
a very short-term deal so they made a
deal but it was for a very short period
of time so that deal would be expiring
very soon yes
Israel and the Saudis to work together
on this issue particularly always I
encourage everybody I want everybody to
work together the Middle East is an
interesting place they historically have
not been working together too well but
no Israel is starting to work together
with a lot of countries that you
wouldn't have thought possible two years
ago yes and I haven't promised the
Saudis that we have to sit down with the
Saudis and work something out and the
Saudis want very much for us to protect
them but I say well we have to work that
was an attack on Saudi Arabia and that
wasn't an attack on us but we would
certainly help them they've been a great
ally they spend 400 billion dollars in
our country over the last number of
years four hundred billion dollars
that's a million and a half jobs and
they're not ones that unlike some
countries where they want terms they
want terms and conditions they want to
say could we borrow the money at 0% for
the next 400 years now now Saudi Arabia
pays cash they've helped us out from the
standpoint of jobs and all of the other
things and they've actually helped us I
would call and I would say listen to our
oil prices are gasoline is too high you
got to let more go you know that I would
call the crown prince and I'd say you
gotta help us out you got to get some
more and all of a sudden the oil starts
flowing into gasoline prices and down OA
the president can do that no other
president was able to do that or maybe
they didn't try but I've done it so now
they're under attack and we will work
something out with them but they also
know that you know I'm not looking to
get into new conflict but sometimes you
have to
I think I'll have a stronger message or
maybe no message at all when we get the
final results of what we're looking at
but right now it's too soon to say
there's plenty of time you know there's
no rush but all here be here a long time
there's no rush
but I'll have a message whether it's a
strong message or maybe no message at
all depending on the final results I'm
not concerned at all personally I'm not
concerned at all we have we have
military power the likes of which the
world has never seen
I'm not concerned at all I'd like to
avoid it you know when I came here three
years ago a most general mattis told me
sir we're very low on ammunition I said
that's a horrible thing to say I'm not
blaming him I'm not blaming anybody but
that's what he told me because we were
at a position where with a certain
country I won't say which one we may
have had conflict and he said to me sir
if you could delay it because we're very
low on ammunition and I said you know
what general I never want to hear that
again from another general no president
should ever ever hear that statement
we're low on ammunition and we now have
more ammunition more missiles more
rockets more tanks more we have more of
everything that we've ever had before
more jet fighters when I came here 50%
of our jet fighters didn't fly you know
that and they were in bad shape and now
we have the best fighters in the world
everybody wants to buy them are you
buying RJR sir which one we have sixteen
that's great good taste thank you that's
a great one so we are a very high on a
munition now that's a story I've never
told before breaking news but we had we
were very low I could even say it
stronger I don't want to say no
ammunition but that gets a lot closer I
said I never want to hear that again and
I never won another president of the
United States to hear that again
could you imagine as president when they
say we're very low on ammunition by the
way stronger than that but I'm not going
to go there that was what I was told and
I said I never want to be on in a
position like that again and he said
could you delay if we do something sir
could you delay it as we fill up and
that is what I inherited from the past
administration and in all fairness to
President Obama two administrations
before President Obama that's what I got
stuck with and we fixed it and we fixed
it good the Crown Prince understands 700
billion the next year 718 billion and
the next year which is right now we just
got a proof of seven hundred and thirty
eight billion dollars and that's a lot
of money even for Bahrain a lot of
months a lot even for Bahrain and
Bahrain has a lot of money okay we're
gonna have to see what happens Steve I
just don't know I can't tell you what's
gonna happen I I could make a prediction
I sort of have a feeling but but we're
gonna have to see what happens it's a
big election that's when we're all gonna
be watching well certainly has a good
chance but it's a very you know it's a
50/50 election a lot of people if you
look at the polls and everything else is
going to be very close so we'll see what
happens polls polls are off and wrong
yeah I don't want to talk about that but
certainly it's something we were told
about that they'd like to do but no I
don't want to be talking about that it's
too soon well just in case we ran a
little bit low on oil we have so much
with the strategic reserves plus being
the number-one producer we can fill them
up very quickly very very quickly and
one of the things I'm doing also is I'm
approving the pipelines in Texas we have
a tremendous pipeline system that's
being held up by various agencies for a
very good reason for going through the
normal process and we're gonna have to
avoid the normal process because if we
that Texas is a massive distributor of
massive producer of oil far bigger than
anybody would have even thought five
years ago so what I'm going to do is
expedite the pipeline approvals that
will get us another 25% energy
additional energy I know this is exactly
the opposite of the Democrats they want
to have wind solar and I guess
make-believe would be the third
alternative right now this is something
we have to do we have the greatest
wealth in the world and we want to be
able to capitalize on it especially when
it comes to safety okay thank you all
very much well I think what I've done
for the inner cities is more than any
president has done for a long time we've
created opportunities owns in fact I did
that with Tim Scott who you know very
well was I think a tremendous guy
it was his initiative and he came to see
me they're having a tremendously
positive impact on the inner cities
including Baltimore including a lot of
other cities that you wouldn't
necessarily think Oakland California is
an example we're having tremendous
success in the inner cities because of
the opportunities as criminal justice
reform I was the one that got it nobody
else I mean we had people that helped
but a group of extremely liberal
Democrats came to the office and they
said we cannot get it President Obama
was unable to get it as you know
President Bush they were all unable to
get it and I got it
and I got it with some very conservative
senators and people that wanted it to
happen and nobody else could have done
it and it's sort of interesting because
they don't like mentioning my name
although I guess now people are
understanding but we got it we got it
done we formed a coalition with some
very conservative people as you know and
some people that are very far left and
we did a thing called criminal justice
reform something that nobody thought the
ground
prince has seen this nobody thought this
could possibly happen and I'm very proud
of criminal justice reform so we did
that we did the opportunity zones that a
lot of other things our job numbers for
african-americans are the best in
history you saw the new ones came out
they're even better than they were two
months ago Hispanic the best in history
Asian the best in history overall
they're phenomenal the best in 51 years
and I think will soon be historic on
that one too the economy is doing great
and that's the best thing I can do know
when I drove through I looked at it and
we flew over but we also know you have
some sections that need a lot of help
and you know what people don't know I
had a great meeting with Elijah Cummings
in this office very early in my tenure
and it was a meeting on drug prices and
I saw him get emotional talking about
drug prices seriously emotional and I
was really impressed he cared about it
and I would certainly be willing to meet
with Elijah and other people if they'd
like but I saw the emotion and the
feeling that he had for reducing drug
prices that we've worked hard and we've
actually had the first year in 51 years
where prices went down but we can get
them down much further we can get the
help from Congress so I think we're
going to do much lower drug prices over
the next year and I think that if Elijah
Cummings would want help I am here but I
did see him at a moment that was
actually I thought a very beautiful
moment I've talked about it often
because I see the political rhetoric
every once in a while and I said that's
not the same guy I had in my office that
was a very caring man that wanted to see
drug prices lower and he and he wanted
that for the community for his community
so I look forward to working with Elijah
but I look forward to working with a lot
of people but I think Opportunity Zones
have been tremendous for the inner
cities and criminal justice reform is
something we're very proud of thank you
oh very much thank you very much
I don't think I have to do outside now
do I do I have to do outside can I go
directly can I go directly to the
helicopters I'll stop by I'll stop by
saying thank you thank you